here you have this again I don't know
this kid
it just all seems interesting to me like
I don't know 24 year old kid doing all
this good work and that he's making a
dime on it too like it's great like it's
it's just great all around but I wanted
to compare that to uh Leonardo DiCaprio
because as you know Leonardo DiCaprio
who I'm sure is worth at least 100
million bucks and he's actually a great
actor he's in a ton of great movies he's
freaking perfect in Wolf of Wall Street
um I even like Titanic there I said it
okay I didn't like the first time I saw
it over the years I've come to enjoy the
Titanic when it's been on TNT in the
afternoon and you know whatever I don't
have cable anymore but okay fine I like
Titanic what are you gonna do
um uh Eli David who's a doctor who does
a ton on covet he had an interesting
tweet about Leonardo DiCaprio as he
wrote Leonardo DiCaprio is very
concerned about climate change fun fact
his mega yacht emits more carbon in a
single trip than your car in your entire
lifetime now look at that yacht there it
turns out that he rents that yacht he
does not own that yacht but isn't that
just the essence of all of this stuff
this same people who will tell you Mr
Beast is a bad dude for doing good stuff
because he's getting attention while
he's doing it and making some money
they're the same people that love
Leonardo Dicaprio and Leonardo DiCaprio
will fly on his private jets all over
the place and he will get on those
Yachts his carbon footprint will be
massive while he guilts you into not
driving car or anything else
[Music]
foreign